I am having the squad I'm having the day
from Lucifer's up in this Creek let's
not even sugarcoat it
coronavirus quarantine life has celebs
like yeah that's Jessica Alba having a
little fun on tick-tock to pass the time
at home she also showed off some dance
moves with her daughter's honor and
Haven not gonna lie she gives me all the
tips and even put her husband cash worn
to the test
who fell in love first who's more
annoying when they're hungry lots of
stars are spending quality time with
their families like Mariah Carey who
rallied her kids and boyfriend for an
epic st. Patty's Day
flip the switch challenge LeBron James's
three kids are also making good use of
their time at home same with love is
blind couple warned and camera
derek hough teamed up with his fellow
world of dance judge neo for a friendly
reminder on social distancing dance but
she don't know how to move an iced out
looking like a star her name is Danny I
don't have know for now Derek is
enjoying time at home with his
girlfriend Hayley they never stopped
dancing not even in the rain Vanessa
Hudgens is also staying active at home
[Music]
but it's this video alongside her BFF
Ashley Tisdale that has all the High
School Musical fans talking
[Music]
I feel like it's such a great way to be
a creator in your own life of like what
you want to put out there I love social
media now we bet you didn't see this one
coming
yeah look to the left that's John
Bongiovi
showing off his choreo skills former
fifth harmony star Ally Brooke took one
of the group's hit songs and turned it
into quarantine content and comedian
Trevor Noah did what he does best make
us laugh so I've been inspired by Italy
and I figure like why don't we do this
in New York
we're also neighbors our units let's be
together you know I can show you the
world shining shimmering
you
[Music]